Sally: This is Systems Sally.
Dude: Hey Sally.
It's Dude.
Sally: Dude, are you OK?
You sound out of breath.
Dude: Well I started growing some
bacterial cells with Izzy last night,
and today I had to get to practice but coach
kept us late and now I'm worried that the cells.
Sally: Dude?
You still there?
The cells what?
Dude Well I guess I don't really know.
Izzy said dog phase but that seems wrong.
Sally: Izzy probably said log phase which is
when the cells are actively
growing and dividing.
If you have some bacteria growing,
I'm happy to put the cultures on ice.
That will slow down their growth, and you
can measure their density when you get here.
Dude: Thanks Sally!
Last night we put two flasks at room
temperature and two in the 37 degrees incubator.
I'll be there as fast as I can.
Izzy: Hi Sally.
Have you seen Dude?
Sally: He just called to say he's on his way.
I'm putting these cultures on
ice, but look: the ones that were
at room temperature don't
seem to have grown much.
Izzy: I was a little afraid of that.
They carry a high-copy protein
generator that Dude and I made,
but the growth of the cells takes a
real hit when they carry this plasmid.
We've seen them spend 12 hours in lag phase and
then take two days to reach stationary phase.
Without the plasmid, it's more
like 4 hours to go from lag
to log and they're saturated overnight.
Sally: When did you start these growing?
Izzy: About 8:00 last night
we diluted the strain 1:1000.
And I don't think these have grown much since
then, but I'll measure their density anyway.
Sally: The cells that were growing at
37 degrees look a little more dense.
Maybe they're doubling at an almost normal rate.
Izzy: Yup.
Their density has definitely changed since
yesterday and if Dude gets here fast,
we might be able to catch them in log
phase and transform in a control device.
Sally: You might also want
to count the cells since some
of the light scattering you're measuring
at the spectrophotometer could
be coming from cell debris.
Izzy: I hadn't thought about
that, but you're right.
I'll teach Dude to count cells when he gets here
Sally: One other thing that I've seen happen is
for the cells to lose a plasmid
if it's making them sick.
You and Dude might want to check
that the cells are still resistant
to whatever antibiotic marker
you have on the plasmid.
Dude: Hi Sally!
Hi Izzy! Sorry to be late.
I hope you've left me some things to do.
Izzy: In lab there's always plenty to do.
Let's get started figuring out what's going on
Dude: Getting here, I saw the most amazing pack
of dogs getting walked over the bridge.